[Music]  divorces nowadays can be messy affairs  but they pale in comparison to the very  strange medieval tradition that is the  marital duel these took place during the  13th century in germany and various  other european countries  a married couple would be given the  chance to resolve their issues if they  were unable to do so then they would  take to the ring for a good old marital  duel in order to make this a somewhat  fair fight the man would be placed  inside of a pit and have one arm tied  behind his back the woman was then given  a sack of rocks and was allowed to move  as she pleased the man was given a  wooden mace to use in his one available  hand but had to remain inside of the pit  the winner was the one who killed or  overpowered their spouse over the coming  centuries this practice was  unsurprisingly phased out and abolished